en el comunicado en el que informa la
decisión la cancillería argentina
explica que le pidió al embajador mateo
capitanich que regrese a buenos aires a
realizar consultas textualmente sobre
las acciones políticas legales
realizadas por el gobierno nicaragüense
en los últimos días que han puesto en
riesgo la integridad y libertad de
diversas figuras de oposición incluidos
precandidatos presidenciales activistas
y empresarios nicaragüenses hasta ahí el
texto del comunicado argentina al igual
que mexico habían sido criticados cuando
días atrás se abstuvieron de votar una
condena contra nicaragua aprobada en la
organización de estados américanos por
26 países argentina y méjico
argumentaron entonces que no estaban de
acuerdo con dejar de lado el principio
de no intervención en asuntos internos
desde la cancillería me dijeron que lo
que motivó que ahora ambos países
llamaron a consultas a sus embajadores
fue que nicaragua siguió adelante con la
detención de opositores y otro
antecedente es que el presidente
argentino alberto fernández le había
pedido al embajador capitanich que
visitara los presos políticos en
nicaragua
11 de junio el canciller argentino
felipe solá le había escrito a su
contraparte nicaragüense pidiéndole por
la liberación de los opositores
detenidos